i'm with new york city's own creator of
everybody loves raymond phil rosenthal
give it up
i'm gonna be here i'm your hype girl um
what better way to celebrate the city
than with a game about its best foods
people i like food it's time for pizza
bagel deli
philip versus kelly
[Music]
but we need a host so let's see if we
can get somebody from new york on the
line
to host this thing hello are you there
well
hello are you are you talking to me
hello
i couldn't hear you hello are you
talking to me wait you sound familiar
i know that voice is this robert de niro
no just
just just call me bobby it's fine just
call me bobby bobby does that sound
familiar you think he's
that's robert deniro that's bobby really
i'm watching you phil i'm watching you
it's all right
start the game start the game i love it
i love it i love it
all right well anyway thank you so much
for hosting today um
bobby um could you tell us how the game
works yeah sure
uh on your board there you've got uh 12
questions about pizza
bagels and bellies uh phil and kelly
stop laughing
phil phil and kelly will take turns
selecting a square now the higher the
points on the square you know the harder
the questions so
this game has played the time but nobody
knows how much time
you know could end at any moment if i
catch my drift phil knows what i mean
it's lights out
so choose your squares wisely you
understand me
now phil you're playing for the left
side of the house seats
and kelly for the right and the winner
gets you know something for the troubles
and
they win a prize for this side sir who
goes first okay well
kelly you go first choose your square go
ahead
okay i'm gonna go for pizza for 400.
pizza pizza for 400. okay guts you got
cats
that's enough phil pipe down okay in the
movie elf
which i wasn't in uh santa claus says
the real original raised pizza is on
what greenwich village street
oh my gosh that's not the right answer
that is not i i ha on sunshine
for a second straight 40 seconds
straight i don't know
unfortunately you're wrong very long
it's it's the answer we're looking for
is 11th
go ahead phil pick something i'll i'll
do uh
bagels for 400. right bagels okay uh
here we go
what iconic new york city bagel uh baker
has the motto like no other bagel in the
world
that's their motto in case you didn't
get that h h
that's correct you're right what that's
right oh
i feel like i'm at a disadvantage here
people okay okay okay this is what i do
okay uh kelly go ahead pick a script
okay i'm gonna go
for i'm gonna go
pizza for a fou no not i don't know do
it no i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go pizza for 200. pizza for
200 okay
his pizza i wanted to be bold right what
is what is the least
popular day of the year for pizza orders
oh
monday sorry kelly that was not the
answer we were looking for
is it like there's not a day is it a
trick question because everybody loves
pizza all the time it was thanksgiving
that's the day oh i thought you were
asking like a day
oh give her another one no it's fine
phil
go go ahead phil uh delhi for 400.
all right deli for 400. okay here we go
and harry met sally this is another
movie i wasn't in
it's ridiculous meg ryan said yes
yes yes you know she's having some
sexual thing that
yeah in what new york city deli did meg
ryan say yes yes yes
this is too easy this is cats is deli
that's right
it was i actually didn't remember that
but i do remember the scene
very well says every woman we actually
named my first uh
food and travel show i'll have what
phil's having after that line
oh good god thank you i think we have a
winner now don't we
yeah phil phillips let's end this for me
wow this is
quite the game everybody yeah yeah thank
you very much
and to have robert de niro hosting is
really that's a cool
it's a forget him all right
so phil ended up winning so that means
everybody on phil's side
is a winner but you know what it's 2020
and this whole year sucks so we all
deserve a trophy
that means everyone's getting a 200 gift
card to lulu
you're welcome that's nice they make
affordable luxury
a reality with all sorts of fresh and
valerity looks they're curated
selections of quality pieces at
reasonable prices coupled with superior
customer service
we'll have you styled for any occasion
[Music]